good morning everyone after a nice talk
of fincent we have another really nice
talk uh it's about transfer learning
with uh
Buri um next to me we have busha chla
and Paul uh
shovi and please please give them a
super warm welcome here you are and
enjoy all right hello everyone and
Welcome to our presentation on transfer
learning with gradient boosted
um who are we we were just introduced
but just some more information we are
two data scientists from in who are
working in Amsterdam um my colleague is
vla she has been a data scientist
withing for about 5 years she has an
academic background in data science my
name is Paul I'm a data science for 2
years and I have a PhD in machine
learning and Psychiatry you can think
for yourself who made the more logical
career trajectory we are part of the
retail banking analytics tribe of in
analytics and the tribe focus is on
analytics products in lending pricing
collection and personalization now if
all of these words don't mean too much
to you we hope that at least one of them
will mean mean something more to you in
a couple of slides and that word is
lending so what in offers to their
customers is an instant lending Prof um
process what that means is that if
you're are a customer of in that means
you have at least one current account
with in and you need a loan for a
purchase I think nowadays this could be
a gr grocery bill you can just go to the
in website and fill out an application
immediately which requires some ID
verification specification of loan
amounts and uh and terms and now comes
the important part if you give in
consent to use your in transactional
data so the historical data in has on
you then you can end uh enter the um
instant lending flow what does that mean
it basically composes out of two main um
checks one check is affordability that
means based on your transactional data
we will uh instantly estimate your
incomes and expenses and we will try to
understand what is the maximum loan
amount you are able to pay back another
part of the puzzle is credit wors also
called acceptance where we use machine
learning models real time on uh
transactional data to try to predict
whether this customer who applied for
the loan uh is likely to default within
a period of one year what does default
mean essentially if or he or she is able
to pay back the loan or not it's a
binary classification problem there of
course also other checks the talk here
will be focused on credit hes if all of
these boxes you know return green then
we can disperse the loan immediately to
the to the applicant if one of the boxes
doesn't approve what the customer asked
for then we will reject the
application why would we want to do that
I think it's fairly straightforward uh
it has all kinds of U benefits for
customers basically it's a very
convenient and easy process you don't
have to upload all kinds of documents
Etc you get a fast response may I say
instant and for in it has also of course
uh advantages namely it's a high degree
of automation meaning that no one needs
to check manually documents Etc this
process just runs and by using machine
learning models in the credit worthiness
and acceptance process we can estimate
your probability of defaulting of not
paying back the loan fairly accurately
which reduces the risk of uh uh which in
has when dispersing Al loan and makes
less losses for a okay that's all good
but what does that have to do with
transfer learning well I just told you
this process is already in place with uh
for customers which are already with ing
so-called known to bank customers we
have a big database of customers which
already applied for loans we have a lot
of transactional data a lot of
transactional history for these
customers and we could build a nice
gradient boosted model like GBM to
predict their risk so to predict their
default basically it performs well
however believe it or not not everyone
is a customer of ing actually there are
two other customer segments uh available
there are so-call fresh to bank
customers which have an account with in
but the history the transaction history
is much lower than for the known to bank
customers they also show in historical
loan applications in a non-instant
process uh different characteristics on
in terms of default rate and defaulting
patterns so the immediate question would
be okay can we enable this instant
lending flow for these fresh to bank
customers um as
well the even bigger uh um sort of thing
which we would like to achieve in the
future is to open this funnel to so-call
new to bank customers those customers by
its name don't have transactional data
with in at all but given a specific EU
directive if they want they can share
their um transactions from a different
EU bank with ing such that they would
also enter this flow but we have no data
on these customers available at in
meaning we cannot train our models on
that so for us the question and the
question of transfer learning would be
how can we model on Fresh to bank
customers and can we use knowledge we
have on our known to bank customers to
uh improve that
process okay before going into any sort
of uh modeling results we need to set up
our machine learning flow just to know
what we're talking about how does it
work it's fairly straightforward we take
all historical inscope data we can have
that includes transactional data and
features derived from it this includes
application information and includes
specifically defaulting information so
it's all historical from loan
applications we already have basically
at
ING this data set is then split across
time essentially to create training and
a test data set the training set for us
is called an intime data set and all the
good machine learning stuff is done on
this feature selection hyper perameter
tuning comparison of different
experiments using cross validation and
final model training and for us again
it's a lgbm classifier the outof time
data set composes the most recent 6
months of data we have available and we
estimate our final performance of the
model using uh area under the receiver
operator curve importantly again just to
to bring this point across we want to
apply and open the instant Landing
funnel for the fresh to bank customers
so all the final performance estimates
also which we will be showing in the
presentation are on those customers good
so what would be the simplest thing you
can do the simplest thing would be not
to do any transfer learning but just
stra straight up machine learning I just
told you that we do have some data of
the fresh to bank customers they don't
have so much transactional history and
we have not so many applications because
they're not coming from an instant
funnel but we do have some data so the
easiest thing to do would be just to
train a model on those customers alone
this is can be considered as our
Baseline model and what we observed when
we did this as a performance was
actually fairly decent more than what we
expected initially however it had came
with a downside that this is a very
small data set and it was a bit unstable
over time so the question became can we
do something better what would be the
next step well still no transfer
learning but at least some transfer what
would happen if we just used the known
to Bank customer segment we take only um
a limited history of transactions
matching the one we have for the fresh
Bank customers and we train a model on
that what you can see here is that we do
observe an improvement in AOC in
comparison to the Baseline model this
Improvement is not high but it is there
we have a larger training data set the
model performance is more stable and
it's a very simple to explain model
right you just train on one data set
apply to another one the next logical
step here would be just to combine
everything together we have data from
fresh to bank we have data from known to
bank how about we just combine them
train on both we still saw an uplift in
comparison to the Baseline model but no
uplift in comparison into the model two
what we uh suspected there is that the
fresh to bank data set is just large
enough to mess up the pattern for the uh
which we learn from the known to Banks
but not large enough to actually
contribute something at least not in
this very simple way okay now some of
you might be if they're still awake
thinking okay the topic of the talk was
transfer learning with gradi in boosting
heard a bit of transfer it heard a bit
of uh learning I heard a bit about
something called instant bending away
whatever the guy was saying but no
transfer learning the good news here is
that this is the time to wake up to pay
attention because buer is going to be
taking you exactly through
that thank you Paul for waking up the
audience for the rest of the
presentation uh let's move to transfer
learning part proper transfer learning
so what you heard from Paul that we
started with a simple experiment where
we technically transfer some knowledge
from not to bank to Fresh bank but
actually this is uh not all you can do
right so this is not a proper way of
doing doing a transfer learning so what
would be the proper way is actually this
so you would start with modeling on no
to Bank customer you would keep this
model as it is and then you would put
some adjustment on top to make it better
performing uh on Fresh to Bank customer
uh
so after uh completing this simple
experiments and learning some things
from uh these fresh to bank and not to
bank customers we mve to this
experiments uh by following this logic
uh this logic is very commonly used in
uh deep learning models like neural
networks right so you can find uh for
example language model uh pretrain
already and then you can put additional
layer at the end and fine-tune on your
data and this will make the pretrain
model better performing uh for your
purpose so obviously we are working in a
credit risk domain and it is regulative
so using deep learning is a bit too
strong statement in in our fields so we
try to find a way to implement the same
logic with the gradient boosted uh trees
so the question for us is it possible to
do this kind of approaches by using uh
boosting trees and for us uh we like to
use light TBM so we uh follow that
direction and luckily the answer is yes
here otherwise I think we wouldn't be
here to share our knowledge from
transfer learning experiments and we
figured out two main approaches one is
refitting approach another one is adding
trees and now I will uh explain both
approaches to you and show the results
at the end and we will uh comment
together uh on the results let's start
with refitting
approach um just to give the general
idea of refitting I would like to make
the problem we are trying trying to
solve a bit simpler and also instead of
thinking about light TBM let's think
about the decision tree which is a unit
component of of light GBM algorithms and
let's say this is our not to Bank
customer we have 17 um uh video Gamers
out of 25 customers and our aim is to
predict uh if the customers like video
games or not with a simple decision tree
um if you fit a decision Tree on this uh
population it would look like this maybe
so you would get two split uh one is
about age and other one is about if the
customers are using computer datab base
so what you did right now you uh split
the main population into some more
homogeneous end leaves and based on
these end leaves now you will uh make a
prediction about your new customers for
example right so if you check the end
leave one the uh probability of having
video gamer now is 33% okay now you fit
a model uh on and out to Bank customer
so this is the first step of a proper
way of doing transfer learning right so
what is the second step it is adjusting
this model so in repeting the adjustment
is done uh only on the end leavs so
you're having the new data set which is
your interest in our case it is fresh to
bank and you're keeping the pattern you
learn from known to bank models which
are these splits about age and using
computer daily basis and then you are
checking the distribution within each
end leave by checking your uh fresh to
bank customers and if we continue the uh
same and leave and leave fun uh you see
the probability of uh having a video
gamer in this group is now 25% so you
change the output from the end leavs
with this way um something to mention
here here you assume that the patterns
you see in no to Bank customer is
completely same with fresh to Bank
customer right so you don't change the
patterns uh available there between
features and the target uh only thing
you are doing is uh you are adjusting
the end leaves to uh maybe show the
target uh base characteristics B
differences in fresh to bank
customers and this was the decision 3
example but we are not using decision 3
and we are not trying to solve this
simple problem in our credit risk domain
and if you go back to the reality in
light GBM model it would look like this
so light GBM uh models have sequential
trees where each tree tries to fix fix
the errors made in the previous trees
right so if you check the uh orange uh
parts so this is the first model you are
fitting on know to Bank customer and
then you are freezing the patterns the
tree structure you figured out in this
part and you are only changing the
distribution of end leaves in the second
step with fresh to bank customers and
how this would look like in the notebook
in your code base uh it would look like
only two line of code and that's it so
you would first fit uh your light TBM
classifier by using a simple fit
function on top of n to bank uh customer
data and now you completed the first
step and second step calling the booster
attribute from this classifier class
because this booster has the three
structure you already figured out from
not Bank customer and then there is a
refit function here and in a refit you
are providing the new data set you would
like to uh focus on which is fresh to
bank and there's also one more parameter
you see right Decay rate so what is this
Decay rate so it is actually a
flexibility lbm gives to you uh it it
acts like sample when you're are
calculating output from each end leave
so you have freedom to say that I would
like to refit on Fresh to Bank customer
but I still would like to keep some uh
information from not to bank and leaves
then you can set up the Decay rate
bigger than zero so this will also give
some weights uh to not to Bank customer
when you are getting output from end
leaves so if you see the plots so Y axis
is before refitting and x-axis is after
repeating and if you set thek rate zero
it means that you're just using fresh to
bank
customers distribution at the end leaves
and it will uh make the probability
differences bigger but if you go with
the default rate the change will be very
minor and in our case we follow thek
rate zero because we wanted to focus on
Fresh to bank customers
specifically so this was the first
approach and as I said this assumes that
patterns are same in two data sets but
in reality probably it is not the case
right probably there are some new
patterns there are patterns that
conflict with the first patterns you
figured out is there a way to adjust the
pattern you learn from the first model
for the second group and the answer is
again yes so there's second approach uh
and it works as adding notes or trees
and if we uh continue the decision three
example uh it would look like this you
would start with two splits you figured
out from no to B customer
uh which are Ag and using computer daily
but you wouldn't stop here you would
investigate further only checking fresh
to Bank customer and you would get two
more splits having kids or having
PlayStation see you uh figured out more
now about your fresh Bank customer and
this will give you to do some
corrections um uh if if you have a
pattern which doesn't fit for FH to B
customer this is the moment for you to
fix by adding new notes uh and if you go
back to light TBM
example so you again fit first tree and
then you are adding more trees
sequentially on top of this first tree
and these new trees are coming from
fresh to bank customers uh and you see
there's no freezing uh split or anything
this is all uh sequential trees at the
end you're combining to come up with the
final model which works better for fresh
to customer and if you check the code
base again it looks just two lines of
code uh so you are first fitting the nor
to bank model and then in the second
model you are giving this first model as
initial model so you say uh second light
GBM please start where I stop in the
first model and continue uh learning
more on this new data set so this sounds
very simple to apply but if you think
deeper it's very hard to optimize it's
very hard to find the uh features which
are op uh which would work best and also
the parameters would work best for this
concept um the important part in our
opinion is about how many trees to add
in the second part because first part
yes you learn the not to Bank customer
you get these patterns but in second
part you have to figure out how much
correction needed how many trees I
should add so if you add for example uh
only one tree new tree from fresh to
bank on top of 100 trees you learn from
not to Bank customer this would wouldn't
make any impact so it would be simply
the same model with the initial one or
let's think the extreme other case so
you had only uh one tree from nonto Bank
customer and added 100 tree from fresh
to Bank customer then you make only you
know uh Standalone fresh to bank model
so there's there must be a optimized uh
uh number of trees you should choose and
what we did here we first focus on the
first model and we find to in that one
we found optimal features and we found
optim
uh parameters and then we kept this as
um as stable so we didn't change the
first part anymore and we only tuned the
second part so with this way we got a
result and now I will show you the
results and I will explain which one we
chose at the
end so here you see the simple
approaches Paul explained and uh you
already know the performance Improvement
and these are the results from transfer
learning with refitting we increase the
a a little bit more than the simple
approaches uh with the transfer learning
we couldn't achieve so big improvements
unfortunately um uh and if you check the
complexity between these um uh
approaches going with the transfer
learning actually uh creates lots of
extra work on us uh we are working in
Risk domain and we have very solid
validation structure at in so every time
when you change something in the
modeling uh you have to explain
everything to them and you have to make
sure that it is exess able from their
side and also business side so thinking
of these extra birt and uh also checking
the A's we decided to go with only uh
using the model on not to Bank customer
but uh as Paul mentioned there was a big
uh characteristic difference we saw on
Fresh to Bank customer about default
rates it is higher than Norm to Bank
customer and to deal with this we just
calibrated this model uh we are using
fresh toan customer at least this
brought the mean U predictions uh to the
correct observed default rate in fresh
to Bank
customer okay so what is the key
takeaway from this talk for you uh do do
we mean all of this transfer learning
stuff is not worth your time of course
the answer is not true uh for us it
didn't uh give a dream results for us on
our use case but it really depends on
the use case right so if your data set
data size is uh so small to do this
trans for learning you will not make it
or if the characteristics of these two
different data sets are not suitable for
this approach again you won't get uh
benefits you expected so what I suggest
you just go and if you have a use case
where you are dealing with the similar
problem just go and try and I think it's
worth to U try give it a try this kind
of approaches in boost streets and for
us it is not the end of the journey
actually we are planning to investigate
this kind of approaches further for
different use cases for example
retraining uh we are thinking to update
your model in the production you don't
have to wait a very long time to collect
this data what you can do just collect
little bit of data and just check you
know if free fitting is helping uh to
improve this model you are using in
production this could be simple idea to
use so in the future we will figure out
and last Point uh our team works with
different countries so we are in global
level of I and we are thinking maybe we
can tailor all already existing models
for different uh countries and different
portfolios uh by using two approaches we
uh work on from proper transfer learning
site so that's all from us today uh if
you have any questions we are happy to
answer right
[Applause]
now